اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
محققون غربيون يتحدثون عن تورط الصين في
مساعده ايران لامداد روسيا بالمسيرات في
حربها على اوكرانيا
وعلى وقع تجدد الاشتباكات في السودان
الاتحاد الافريقي يحذر من حرب اهليه ويدعو
لانهاء القتال فورا
رئيس البرلمان الليبي يقول ان صياغه قانون
الانتخابات رئاسيه من جولتين هدفه افشال
هذا الاستحقار
وعشيه مثول ترامبا امام المحكمه
الفيدراليه انصاره يدعون للتظاهر ومصيره
القانوني في يد احد
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه كشف
تقرير اعده محققون غربيون نقلته صحيفه
كشف ان الصين تساعد ايران على تسريع امداد
روسيا بالمسيرات وقال المحققون في التقرير
انه تم رصده مكونات صينيه في مسيره
ايرانيه استخدمتها روسيا خلال الحرب في
اوكرانيا واضافوا ان المكونات الصينيه في
المسيره تم صنعها في منتصف يناير الماضي
واشارت تقرير الى السرعه التي تم فيها
تصنيع المكون الصيني في يناير ثم شحنه الى
ايران وتركيبه هناك وارسال المسيره الى
روسيا واستخدامها في الحرب في ابريل
الماضي
التقرير الذي اعده محققون في شركه تتخذ من
بريطانيا مقرا لها ومتخصصه في تعقب حركه
الاسلحه عالميا اكد ايضا ان الصين مستمره
في شحن مكونات المسيرات الى ايران
في اخر تطورات الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاده
افادت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه هانا
ماليار افادت ان قوات كييف استعادت قريه
رابعه وهي ستورغوف الواقعه في اقليم
دونيسك بجنوب شرق البلاد من ايادي القوات
الروسيه
وكانت قد اعلنت استعاده ثلاث قرى هي
بلاهودان
ونسكتشني
ووفق مسؤولين اوكران ما زالت المعارك
العنيفه مستمره في بخمه شرقا اوكرانيا مع
تاكيدهم على تقدم القوات الاوكرانيه 700
متر باتجاه المدينه
واوضح المسؤولون ان القوات الروسيه قصفت
مواقعهم اكثر من 200 مره
بينما دمرت القوات الاوكرانيه مركبتين
قتاليتين للقوات الروسيه ومدفعي هاون
ومستودعا للذخيره
في المقابله اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان قواتها صدت محاولات القوات الاوكرانيه
لمهاجمه منطقتين دونسك
وقالت انها ضربت اهدافا بصواريخ عاليه
الدقه اطلقتها من البحر
وقال المتحدث باسم الوزاره ايغور
ان الضربه حققت اهدافها ودمرت جميع
المرافق المحدده لهذا الاستهداف
من موسكو ينضم الي لمزيد من المتابعه
مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد عبد
الجواد اهلا وسهلا بك جديد اخبار المعارك
عبد الجواد وهل صحيح ان كيف استعاده اربع
قرى في دوناتسك هل علقت موسكو على هذا
الكلام
مرحبا طالب موسكو لم تعلق رسميا على قضيه
الكره التي يتحدث عنها الجانب الاوكراني
بالرغم من ان بعض وسائل الاعلام غير
الحكوميه قامت بنشر مثل هذه الاخبار
الطالب بيان وزاره الدفاع الاخير لم يتطرق
لهذا الموضوع لكن كما هو ملاحظ من هذا
البيان هو حسب الكثير من التحليلات
السياسيه في البلاد فان موسكو عادت
لاستخدام ضرباتها الصاروخيه التي توجه من
داخل البحر من على السفن الى مناطق مختلفه
يدور الحديث عن استهداف مناطق عسكريه
اوكرانيه بالاضافه الى نقاط حيويه على
محاور عده بالاضافه الى صد هجمات مختلفه
ابرزها يكمن في كراسن
في زبروجي في محور دانيتك وفي محور من
الشيعه الغربيه
يعني الجهه الغربيه الشماليه كما يقول
تم اسقاط اربع مسيرات اوكرانيه حسب روايه
الدفاع طالب في المقاطعات الاربعه
اما في النقاط الساخنه على الشريط الحدودي
الفاصل بين روسيا واوكرانيا فخرج عمده
وحاكم وتحدث عن ان اعداد الضربات
الاوكرانيه على هذا الاقليم انخفضت بشكل
كبير ولم تتعدى حاجز الخمسه والاربعين
ضربه خلال الساعات الاربعه والعشرين
الماضيه كما هو ملاحظ من الانبا الوارده
من هناك طالب فان احدى المسيرتين التي تم
ايصالها الى منطقه بيلغراف قد استهدفت
قطارا كان يسير وخرجت عرباته بالاضافه الى
تضرر السكك الحديديه هناك لقطات طبعا قامت
حكومه بنشرها طالب تظهر دمرا بالقرب من
محطه دانيسك للسكك الحديديه العديد من
المحال التجاريه تضررت هناك لكن كل هذا
طالب ياتي على التصريحات السياسيه التي
خرج بها ديمر بوتين وتحدث وحديث هذا يعتبر
نادرا بما يخص الضربات الاوكرانيه
والعمليه العسكريه بتفاصيلها تحدث بانكيف
تقوم باستهداف المناطق السكنيه يعني
بالرغم من ان هذا لا يعني شيئا في عمليه
الصراع العسكريه نقطه اخيره لو سمحت لي
بها طالب ايضا يدور الحديث من حكومه
بيليجراد بان مناطق تواجد اللاجئين يتم
استهدافها في بعض الاحيان ان كانوا لاجئين
في المناطق التي تم اخراج اليها سكان
المناطق التي عانت من الفيضانات او
اللاجئين في تفضل طالب هل يرى المسؤولون
الروس ان الهجوم المضاد اصيب بانتكاسه
كبرى عبد الجواد ام لا يعني
ينتظرون ويقولون ان هذه المساله لم تتمظهر
بشكل كبير بعد باختصار
طالب يعني رغم الاعلان عن ان موسكو تحضر
لهجوم قد يكون مضاد لكن طبعا على الصعيد
الرسمي على كافه التحليلات السياسيه
الثقيله ان صح التعبير في البلاد فان
موسكو اليوم تسعى لمد واحكام القبض على
خطها الدفاعي لابعاد القوات الاوكرانيه
قدر الامكان عن المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
موسكو في الجنوب الاوكراني لذلك الحديث عن
الهجوم المضاد تتحدث عنه وزاره الدفاع
بشكل يومي مجلس الامن الخارجيه والكرملين
لكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم تعرف ما هي طريقه
الرد التي ستقوم بتقديمها موسكو خلال
الفترات القادمه لكن حسب التحليلات
السياسيه كما ذكرت موسكو ذاهبا نحو احكام
القبض على خطها الدفاعي لابعاد القوات
الاوكرانيه قدر الامكان نحو الشمال من
موسكو مراسل العربي عبد الجواد الرشود
شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الجواد على هذه
المشاركه
قال مفاوض السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي ان اي مفاوضات سلام بشان
اوكرانيا لن تحدث قبل تحديد الفائز في
انتخابات الرئاسه الامريكيه في العام 20
24 واضاف بوريل في تصريحات صحفيه ان
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ينتظر نتائج
الانتخابات الامريكيه مشيرا الى انه لا
يجب توقع بدء مفاوضات السلام قبل ذلك
وفي رساله موجهه الى روسيا انطلقت تدريبات
لحلف شمال الاطلسي بتنسيق من المانيا
والتي تعد من اكبر المناورات الجويه في
تاريخ الناتو وتستمر حتى الثالث والعشرين
من يونيو
وتهدف المناورات الى اظهار وحده الاعضاء
في مواجهه اي تهديدات محتمله حيث ستشارك
قرابه 250 طائره عسكريه من 25 دوله عضوا
في الحلف او شريكه له بما فيها اليابان
والسويد الدول المرشحه لعضويه النيتو
اضافه الى مشاركه ويصل من عشره الاف جندي
في هذه التدريبات خصوصا من المانيا وايضا
من جمهوريه التشيك واستونيا ولاتفيا كما
وستعزز هذه التدريبات توافقيه التشغيل
والحمايه من الطائرات بدون طيار وصواريخ
كروس في حال وقوع هجوم على مدن او مطارات
او موانئ واقعه على اراضي دول الحلف
على كل ماء من برلين مزيد من المتابع حول
هذا الموضوع مراسله العربيه راغده اهلا
وسهلا بك اي رسائل تحميلها هذه المناورات
الاضخم في تاريخ الناتو وهل روسيا هي
المستهدفه مباشره يعني ما في يعني ما في
قفازات هذه موجهه الى روسيا
اهلا بك بالطبع يعني ولكن قاده النيتو
والزعماء الالمان يعني القاده العسكريين
الالمان الذين يقضون هذه العمليه كانوا
حريصين على القول بانه ليست روسيا هي
المستهدفه ولكن السفيره الامريكيه في
برلين قبل يومين عندما كانت تتحدث عن
المشاركه الامريكيه في هذه المناوره كانت
واضحه بان هذه رساله لكل من يريد ان يرى
كما قالت وسمى التحديدا من بين هؤلاء
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين لذلك من دون
شك رساله موجهه لروسيا رغم انه هذه
العمليه يعني تم الاتفاق عليها ويتم
التحضير لها منذ قرابه الاربع سنوات يعني
قبل ان تبدا العمليه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
ولكن منذ ان بدات هذه العمليه الروسيه
بطبيعه الحال يعني كل خلفيه هذه التدريبات
الان باتت مختلفه ولكن سمعنا اليوم صباحا
ايضا من الجنرال الالماني الذي يقود هذه
العمليه بانه سيكون هناك محاوله او يعني
محاوله لتجنب اي تصعيد من او يعني توجيه
رسالات تعتبرها روسيا بانها ربما
استفزازيه قال بانه الطائرات لن يعني
تتوجه لن تكون باتجاه كلينينجراد التي هي
محاذيه يعني لالمانيا هي تقع بين ليتوانيا
وبولندا ولذلك ستتفادى هذه القوات ان
تتوجه فوق هذه المنطقه تفاديا لاستفزاز
روسيا ولكن من دون شك يعني مشاركه 25 دوله
مشاركه هذه المشاركه الامريكيه الكبيره
جدا ربما هي بمفردها يعني دلاله كبيره
لانه من اصل 250 مقاتله الولايات المتحده
لوحدها ارسلت مئه مقاتله منها وهذا يعني
بانه بالطبع اوروبا ما زالت تعتمد على
الولايات المتحده في امنها والولايات
المتحده من جهتها ايضا تريد ان ترسل رساله
بانها ملتزمه بامن اوروبا راقده في الاونه
الاخيره كثر الكلام عن امكانيه انه من
السيناريوهات المقبله لحلف الناتو من
الاوراق ارسال قوات من دول اعضاء فيه على
الارض هل هنالك حديث جدي خلال هذه
المناورات عن امكانيه ارسال عديد من قوات
النيتو الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه للمشاركه
في هذا القتال ام لا هذا مستبعد تماما
[موسيقى]
يعني هذه هي التدريبات تعمل على مواجهه
سيناريو رسمته يعني قاده ترسمه قاده
الناتو بانه هناك اعتداء او عمليه تنظمها
قوات غريبه على الشواطئ الالمانيه محاكاه
لهجوم على الشواطئ الالمانيه تحديدا على
مرفا رستم على بحر البلطيق ليس هناك اي
ذكر لاوكرانيا ليس هناك اي ذكر بالاسم
باستثناء ما تحدثت به السفيره الامريكيه
عن روسيا حتى ولكن يعني هذه هذه
الاستعدادات الكبيره بالطبع هي تحاكي
ربما هجوم محتمل تعد له قوات النيتو ابعد
من اوكرانيا على اراضي بولندا على اراضي
المانيا التي دائما هي يعني المانيا
تحديدا تتعرض لتهديدات من قبل المسؤولين
السياسيين الروس بانه في حال تخطيتهم
الخطوط الحمر فانه دوركم سياتي لذلك هو
ايضا امتحان لالمانيا لانه المانيا تعلم
بانه في السنوات الماضيه خاصه تحت اداره
ترامب كان هناك دائما مطالبات لها بان
تكون اكثر ملتزمه بان تزيد من دفاعاتها
انفاقها الدفاع القوات النيتو وموقعها
الجغرافي بطبيعه الحال وسط اوروبا يجعلها
يعني ربما المرشح الافضل ان تستقبل هذه
التدريبات من برلين مراسله العربيه راغده
برنامج شكرا جزيلا لك راغده على كل هذه
المتابعه
حضر رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي موسى
فكي من ان استمرار الصراع في السودان يهدد
بجر البلاد الى حرب اهليه واسعه النطاق
واضاف فكي خلال قمه الايجاد في جيبوتي ان
الازمه السودانيه تتطلب حلا سريعا وموحدا
من دون اي تاجيل واشار الى ان المفوضيه
الافريقيه تشجعوا على حوار شامل يقوده
السودانيون بانفسهم لحل الازمه وشدد على
ان عمليه الدمار الذاتي المستمره في
السودان يجب ان تتوقف مؤكدا ان الازمه
تهدد المنطقه باكملها
زي اكستريم سريوس الازمه العميقه والعنفه
في السودان والتهديدات الخطيره التي
تمثلها لوجود هذه البلاد والمنطقه كلها
واضحه جدا كل التحليلات تتفق على ان هذه
الحرب في حال لم تتوقف ستفدي لاندلاع حرب
اهليه وستعم الفوضى كما انها ستؤدي
لانهيار الدوله بالكامل الاليه الثلاثيه
التزمت بتوفير الدعم للسودان لوقف الحرب
وتوفير المساعدات الانسانيه لكل من يحتاج
اليها كما تلتزم بمساعده السودانيين الى
الذهاب نحو حوار وطني شامل ومخطط يقوده
السودانيون انفسهم بعيدا عن اي تاثيرات
خارجيه
[موسيقى]
ميدانيه نعلن الجيش السوداني في بيان الله
وان قواتها الحقت بعناصر الدعم السريع
خسائر فادحه خلال اليومين الماضيين عقبا
انتهاء الهدنه الاخيره صباحا وذكر الجيش
ان خسائر الدعم السريع شملت مقتله مئات
العناصر وتدميرها عشرات الاليات العسكريه
وذكر الجيش ان قوته قامت بعمليه تنشيط في
منطقه الشجره جنوبي الخرطوم وجسر الحلفايه
وشرق النيل لافتا الى ان قوات الدعم تتخفى
بالملابس المدنيه وتستخدم سيارات منهوبه
في تحركاتها كما تحتمي بمنازل المواطنين
بحسب بيان الجيش
نشاه الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
الصين تنفي مجددا التقارير حول تجسسها على
الولايات المتحده عبر الاراضي الكوبيه
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه اعتبر رئيس مجلس النواب الليبيه
عقيل صالحه ان صياغه قانون اجراء
الانتخابات الرئاسيه من جولتين في البلاد
هدفه التعطيل وقال صالح خلال جلسه
برلمانيه لمناقشه اعمال اللجنه المشتركه
في مجلس الدوله ان البرلمان لم يتسلم من
اللجنه اي قانون بشكل رسمي حتى الان واشار
الى ان التعديل الدستوري يؤكد ان اللجنه
المشتركه سته زائد سته تستمد سلطتها منه
ولا يحق له او لرئيس مجلس الدوله التوقيع
على مسوده القانون التي تم التوصل اليها
في بوزنيقه في المغرب
[موسيقى]
اكدت الخارجيه الايرانيه ان اي اتفاق سيتم
التوصل اليه بشان الملف النووي يجب ان
يحمي مصالح مصالح ايران
ويراعي الخطوط الحمراء وقال المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني ان ايران
لا تجري اي مباحثات لابرام اتفاق النووي
مؤقت او جديد وان اي تفاوض يجب ان يكون
على اساس اتفاق 2015
واشار ايضا الى احتماليه حدوث تبادل
للسجناء مع واشنطن قريبا اذا اظهرت
الولايات المتحده حسن النيه استدل
منطقيه ما هو مؤسسه الرهبانيه التصريحات
الصادره عن الخارجيه الايرانيه جاءت بعد
ان فتح المرشد الايراني علي خميني الباب
امام امكانيه ابرام اتفاق مع الغرب حول
انشطه بلادها النوويه حيث قال ان هذا
الامر ليس مستحيلا لكنه شدد على ضروره الا
يمس ببنيه بلاده التحتيه لانشطتها النوويه
موافقه خامنئي الحدره جاءت بعد ايام من
نفي كل من طهران مباشرنتون صحه تقرير ذكر
انهما
تقتربان من ابرام اتفاق مؤقت تكبح بموجبه
ايران برنامجها النووي مقابل تخفيف
العقوبات
ومع ذلك طالب مني هيئه الطاقه الذريه
الايرانيه بمواصله العمل مع الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه في اطار من
الضمانات داعيا الى عدم الرضوخ للمطالب
التي وصفها بالمبالغ فيها والخاطئه
للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه حسب
تعبيرها
طالب باحترامي قانون اقره البرلمان
الايراني في عام 2020
تعلق بموجبه طهران عمليات التفتيش التي
تجريها الوكاله الدوليه على المواقع
النوويه الايرانيه اذا لم ترفع العقوبات
اخيرا تم مؤخرا نشر اخبار حول الاتفاقيه
المؤقته او مواضيع من هذا القبيل نحن
نعتبر هذه التكهنات اعلاميه اكثر من اي
شيء اخر او ربما اخبارا تنشرها بعض
الاطراف بدوافع سياسيه خاصه بها او لتعطيل
العمليه الحاليه من المفاوضات ليس لدينا
ما يسمى التفاوض على اتفاقيه مؤقته ولا
نؤيد الترتيبات الجديده لتحل محل
الاتفاقيه النوويه
لكن السؤال الان هو الى اي مدى وصل برنامج
ايران النووي وهل باتت ايران على اعتاب
صنع القنبله النوويه
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه اعلنت في
تقرير سابق لها ان مخزون ايران المقدر من
اليورانيوم المخصب بلغ اكثر من 23 ضعفا
للحد المنصوص عليه في اتفاق 2015
مدير الوكاله رافائيل بروسي اعلن مطلع
الشهر الجاري ان الوكاله نجحت في تركيب
اجهزه لمراقبه التخصيب في منشاتي فوردو
وناتنز الايرانيتين الا ان جراس اعتبر
الخطوه غير كافيه لمراقبه انشطه الظهران
النوويه وقال ان مخزون ايران من
اليورانيوم المخصبه ارتفع باكثر من الربع
في ثلاثه اشهر
واوضح ان ذلك يشمل مخزونها من اليورانيوم
المخصب بنسبه تصل الى 20% والذي يقترب من
نصف طن اما مخزونها من اليورانيوم العالي
التخصيب فيصل الى نسبه 60% والذي يزيد على
100 كيلوغرام
ويقول الخبراء ان 50 كجما تكفي بالفعل
لصناعه سلاح نووي في حال كان اليورانيوم
مخصبا اكثر بقليل
الاتفاق النووي الايراني ابرم في الرابع
عشر من يوليو 2015 في فيينا توصلت ايران
وامريكا وبريطانيا وفرنسا وروسيا والصين
والمانيا الاتفاق ان عرف بالسن خطه العمل
الشامل المشتركه بموجبه باتت تخضع انشطه
ايران النوويه لبرنامج الرقابه وتفتيش
تابع للوكاله الذريه
الثامن من مايو 2018 اعلان الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب انسحاب
بلاده احاديا من الاتفاق وفرض عقوبات على
ايران
مطالب ايران للعوده الى الاتفاق النووي
ضمانات امريكيه بعدم انسحاب اي رئيس
مستقبلا من الصفقه
تخلل وكاله الذريه عن تحقيق مدته ثلاث
سنوات في اليورانيوم المخصب في منشات
ايرانيه مختلفه
معي من طه لمزيد من المتابع لهذا الموضوع
استاذ العلوم السياسيه الدكتور مصدق بور
ومن باريس ينضم اليها المحلل السياسي طارق
ابدا معك من طهران هل فعلا يمكن ان تقبل
طهران باتفاق مؤقت في حال كان يراعي
مصالحها ام لا ما تريده طهران هو الاتفاق
السابق بحذافيره وغير ذلك لا
نعم شكرا
ايران طبعا اولا اريد ان اتحدث عن الاتفاق
يعني هذا الاتفاق هو بقي منه يعني مده سنه
واحده فقط وهذا الاتفاق اساسا لا يجدي
بحكم الميت ولكن ايراني متمسكه في هذا
الاتفاق لانه يوفر الاطار وارضيه للعمل
المشترك اما ايران
لن توافق على اتفاق مؤقت او اتفاق اضافي
حتى
انما يجري ايضا حاليا هو ببساطه عمانيه
يعني العمل هو نحو باتجاه
مسوده عمل او باتجاه يعني
شيء مكتوب
وليس الرسمي ايضا لان ظروف الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لا تسمح لها حاليا بسبب
الانتخابات بسبب مشاكل ايران ومشاكل خاصه
بها وبالتالي
هذا الموضوع وهي تسعى لاصوله الى الى حل
يعني
متقابل يعني هل يضمن مصالحها يعني تجميد
مقابل تجميل هذا ما تريده ايران حاليا لا
تريد يعني ان يكون هناك
اضافي
لاسال الاستاذ طارق وهبي في باريس طارق
طيب لماذا عادت الان وفي الهزيع الاخيره
انصح التعبير من عمر اداره الرئيس
الامريكي الحالي جو بايدن عادت نغمه
العوده الى اتفاق سواء مؤقت او جزئي يعني
ما عدا مما بدا يعني والرئيس بايدن الان
هو اكثر من بطه عرجاء
صحيح مساء الخير استاذ طالب شكرا
للاستضافه وتحيه لضيفك من طهران سيدي
العزيز يعني سؤالك مئه بالمئه صحيح بمعنى
ان الان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ترى
ان التقارب السعودي الايراني هو شيء مهم
جدا
بمفهوم العلاقات الثنائيه ما بين ايران
والسعوديه والتدخل الصين للوصول الى هذا
الموضوع اكثر اهتماما ولذلك لا تريد
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان
تكون خارج هذه اللعبه التي تحصل في الشرق
الاوسط حاليا بواساطه صينيه وايضا يجب ان
يقول ان التدخل الايراني بمفهوم الحرب
الاوكرانيه ومساعده روسيا بالطائرات
المسيره التي اثبتت انها فعاله وانها تضرب
باماكن معينه مهمه جدا على ارض المعركه
لذلك كل هذه العوامل ادت الى ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه رات ان ممكن ان يكون
هناك
عن ما تيار مناسب
للعوده الى ما نسميه
انا برايي لا يوجد اتفاق لانه مشكله ايران
اذا اردنا ان ناخذ بدقيه وبحرفيه الترجمه
الفارسيه لما قاله المرشد هو الامكانيه
للتوصل مع الغرب
للتفاوض ولكن مشروط بعدم المس بالبنيه
التحتيه لما نسميه
الثقافه النوويه او خلينا نقول
كل ما يسمى الارث العلمي الذي له علاقه
بالمفهوم النووي لذلك انا براي البث
المتحده الامريكيه هي الان امام
نوعا ما
ان الفشل الذي حصل فيينا منذ عام 2021 حتى
الان لم يعطي اي دليل اكثر من ذلك يعني
خلينا نقول انه ما يحصل الان
بعوده ما يسمى مدفوعات بين قوسين من عراق
الى ايران يعني عم نحكي باربع مليار دولار
وكان فاتوره طاقه والعمل انه غدا غدا
كوريا الجنوبيه ستدفع ايضا كل هذه تمهيدات
وبالاحرى التنازلات امريكيه لوضع حد لبعض
المطالب العاليه او السقف العالي اللي قد
تطلبه ايران نذكر النيران كانت ترفض ان
يكون الحرس الثوري على لائحه العراق نفكر
ان ايران كانت ترفض ان يدخل كل برنامج
قليل الا تلاحظ معي ان من يتراجع هي اداره
الرئيس بايدن وليس ايران ولكن دعني انتقل
الى السيد مصدق مجددا دكتور مصدق هل طهران
متحمسه لاعطاء اداره بايدن اي انجاز سياسي
يمكن ان تصرفه في الانتخابات الامريكيه
والا لماذا كل هذا الحراك الان اذا لم تكن
تريد الاداره الامريكيه صرف اي انجاز
سياسي على المستوى الملف النووي الايراني
في الانتخابات هل هذا هو مربط الفرس هنا
نعم يعني الى ان تشعر بان الابانه
الامريكيه هي اصبحت يعني في وضع تحتاج الى
هذا الاتفاق وتحتاج الى الى نوع من طرق
النجاه ان لم ابالغ في كلامه يعني
الانتخابات وبالتالي ايضا هناك بموازات
ذلك هناك مؤشرات ايجابيه كما تفضل الاستاذ
ضيفي الكريم هناك مؤشرات ايجابيه يعني فك
تجميد عن الاصول الايرانيه الموجوده في
العراق وهي تقدر يعني حاليا الدفعه الاولى
مليارين و700 الف
مليون دولار وايضا هناك صفقه لتبادل
السجناء نعتقد هذا الشيء ايضا سوف يتحقق
وهناك ايضا
جدا لن تشعر بان هناك خلاف حقيقي بدا بين
اداره نتانياهو الاداره الديمقراطيه
وبالتالي نحن عندما نسمع ان نعيق والصراخ
الاسرائيلي هذا مؤشر
على على ان الموقف الامريكي لا باس منه
حاليا ويمكن
الاعتماد اليوم الخارجيه الايرانيه يعني
اكدت بانها
وسوف تسعى
دكتور مصدق يعني كلامك واضح ان الموقف
الامريكي الان لا باس منه طيب ساعود اليك
ولكن لاعزاء المشاهدين لنشاهد موقف المرشد
الاعلى علي خامنئي الموقف الامريكي لم
ياتي بجديد اعزائي المشاهدين الامريكيه
امتنعت عن التعليق مباشره على تصريحات
المرشد الاعلى علي خمينا لكنها اكدت موقف
اداره الرئيس بايدن بان واشنطن ملتزمه
بعدم السماح ابدا لايران بامتلاك سلاح
النووي وذكرت ايضا ان الدبلوماسيه هي افضل
سبيل لانهاء المساله لكنها اكدت ان بايدن
لم يستبعد اي خيارات اخرى في سبيل تحقيق
ذلك
استاذ طارق اعود الى سؤالي لسالتك قبل ان
انتقل للدكتور مصدق الا تلاحظ معي ان من
يتراجع هي واشنطن يعني وان ايران تربح
بالنقاط هنا ام لا هذا الكلام غير صحيح
الطالب منذ بدء ما نسميه عوده المفاوضات
لعوده الولايات المتحده الامريكيه للاتفاق
النووي او التزام ايران ايضا بهذا الاتفاق
بعد خروجه وراينا ان عدد كبير من التقارير
للوكاله الدوليه الطاقه الذريه هناك نقاط
سوداء للحكومه الايرانيه بهذا الموضوع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تحاول ان
تطمئن انها بهذا الملف تستطيع ان تستعيد
ما نسمينه اليد حول ما يسمى الخوف الكبير
اي امتلاك الطاقه الذريه بمعنى القنبله
النوويه لايران ولذلك الحراك الامريكي
الذي نراه الان هو عباره عن ان امريكا
فقدت في مرحله معينه اليد امام ما كانت هي
تريده في كل ما يحصل يعني لو الرئيس ترامب
نجح في الانتخابات كان هناك تصعيد اخر
بطريقه بطريقه المعالجه الاير ولكن مجيء
الرئيس بايدن او الديمقراطينا الحكم اوصل
الى ان هناك طاقه امل لكي نصل الى وللاسف
الشديد انا لا اعتقد انها العوده قد تكون
بهذه البساطه لانه الشروط عاليه من كلا
الطرفين وحتى لو ان اسرائيل كما وصفها
ضيفك من من
طهران بالقول ان اسرائيل غير يعني
سعيده بما يحصل ولكن بنفس الوقت هي متوتره
والوضع في الشرق الاوسط جد متوتر في هذا
الموضوع ولا احد يعرف الى اي مدى قد تصل
هذه المفاوضات ببساطه خليجيه لانه لا يجب
ان ننسى ان وزير الخارجيه الامريكي كان
بمجلس التعاون الخليجي وكان مجلس التعاون
الخليجي اثنى على الموضوع الايراني
السعودي وهذا لا تستطيع
ساكتفي بهذا القدر من باريس المحل السياسي
طارق وهبي ومن طهران استاذ العلوم
السياسيه الدكتور مصدق شكرا جزيلا لكما
على هذه المشاركه
هذا وذكرت مصادر للعربيه ان مصر تبحث
مقترحات قدمها وسطاء لعقد اجتماع مباشر مع
ايران للاتفاق على شكل عوده العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه وقالت المصادر ان الوسطاء
طرحوا عقد اجتماع بين مسؤولين امنيين بمصر
وايران كما عرضت دولتان عربيتان استضافه
هذه المباحثات لتقريب وجهات النظر واشارت
المصادر الى انه لم يتم التوصل الى موعد
محدد لاتخاذ خطوات دبلوماسيه بين البلدين
واضافت المصادر ايضا ان القاهره لا تزال
تقيم كافه الامور ومقترحات الوسطاء قبل
اتخاذ اي قرار للتقارب مع طهره
وكانت الاشاره الايرانيه لاعاده العلاقات
مع مصر اكثر وضوحا على مدار الاشهر
الماضيه والتي كان اخرها اليوم حينما قال
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر
كنعاني ان بلاده ترحب باعاده العلاقات مع
مصر اذا ما رغبت القاهره في ذلك واضاف في
مؤتمر صحفي انه تم بالفعل التعبير عن موقف
واضح للحكومه بالنسبه لعوده العلاقات مع
القاهره مؤكدا ان العلاقات مع دول المنطقه
من اولويات بلاده
افاد المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان بمقتل
روسي واصابه اربعه اخرين وذلك في قصف
مدفعي تركي بريف حلب الشمالي وذكر المرصد
ان القصف استهدف رتلا روسيا على طريق حربا
المدفعة تحليق مروحيات روسيه في سماء
المنطقه لنقل الجرح
اكاد وزير الطاقه والمياه اللبنانيه وليد
فياض ضروره دفع تكلفه استهلاك اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين والسوريين من الكهرباء في
البلاد ملمحا لامكانيه قطع الكهرباء عن
المخيمات في حال عدم السدا
لازم ندفع حق الكهرباء لانه هذه الكهرباء
اللي عم تتامل يوم عم تتامل الى كلفه ويجب
ان تغطي ان كان الانتاج او التشغيل او
التوزيع او الصيانه او المعاشات كله هيدا
لازم يتغطى وبيتغطى
وطبعا مش مطلوب من اللبنانيين انه يغطوا
كلفه استهلاك
الاخوان السوريين والفلسطينيين كل واحد
بده يخطي كلفه استهلاكه
في متابعه للتصعيد بين واشنطن وبيكين قالت
وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه ان التقارير التي
تفيد بتجسس بيكين على الولايات المتحده من
كوبا لا اساس لها من الصحه وهي خاطئه
ونددت بالتحركات التي قامت بها واشنطن
ووسائل الاعلام الامريكيه التي نشرت
معلومات غير متسقه على حد قولها
في الاسبوع الماضي اوضحت بالفعل موقف
بيكين بشان المساله المتعلقه بالتقارير
الخاطئه التي تتهم الصين بالتجسس على
الولايات المتحده من كوبا راينا كيف
تعاملت الاداره الامريكيه ووسائل الاعلام
التي نشرت قدرا كبيرا من المعلومات
الخاطئه حول البناء المزعوم لما تسمى
بمنشات التجسس الصينيه في كوبا مره اخرى
اقول بان هذه مجرد مهزله وضعتها الولايات
المتحده المتناقضه مع نفسها
نشاطنا مستمره وفي ايضا
[تصفيق]
وفاه رئيس وزراء ايطاليا السابق سيلفيو
برلو سكوني وميلوني
وتقول انه احد اكثر الرجال تاثيرا في
تاريخ ايطاليا
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشاط الخامسه من
العربيه الى الولايات المتحده فعشيه مثول
لرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب امام
المحكمه في قضيه الوثائق المسربه دعا
انصاره الى الاحتجاج امام محكمه ميامي
بولايه فلوريدا وذلك رفضا لتوجيه
الاتهامات بحق الرجل الساعي للعوده الى
البيت الابيض حيث اعتبروا انها تستند الى
دوافع سياسيه
المفارقه الان اعزائي المشاهدين هي ان
صدور لائحه الاتهامات الفيدراليه ضد ترامب
تستند الى ادله اخذت من عضو في فريقه
القانوني
ايفان كوركران الذي تم تعيينه لتمثيل
ترامب بعدما اصدرت وزاره العدل مذكره
استدعاء للحصول على وثائق السريه من
مارلاجو يمكن ان يكون شاهدا رئيسيا في
القضيه حسب صحيفه
كما ان ملاحظات كور كوران اعطت المدعين
العامين بشكل اساسي خارطه طريق لبناء
قضيتهم
فوفقا للائحه الاتهام ضغط ترامب على كور
كوران لمنع المحققين من استعاده ملفات من
المواد السريه بل واقترح عليه ايضا الكذب
وحجب الوثائق بشكل كلي عن المحققين
واظهرت الملاحظات وفقا لنيورك تايمز
محادثات تساءل في ترامب عما سيحدث في حال
عدم التعاون مع المحققين
ليتوقف مصيره ترامب القانوني الان اعزائي
المشاهدين على شهاده وادله من رجلين دفع
لهما للدفاع عنه وهما كوركران الذي ما
يزال عضوا في فريقه القانوني ومايكل كوهن
المحامي السابق لترامب الذي ساعد المدعين
العامين في نيويورك في قضيتهم المتعلقه
بدفع اموال سريه من قبل ترامب لنجمه
اباحيه قبل انتخابات عام 2016
الى واشنطن لمزيد من المتابع ينضم الي
مراسل العربيه فرغانم بير اهلا وسهلا بك
ما الذي سنشهده غدا سواء داخل المحكمه في
ميامي او خارج المحكمه مع دعوه انصار
ترامب الى التظاهر والاحتجاج بقوه
سوف نرى استعاده لما حدث في نيويورك منذ
عده اسابيع ترامب ياتي الى المحكمه
الكاميرات موجوده في الشارع ولكننا لن نرى
شيئا كثيرا داخل القاعه بالاضافه الى ذلك
هناك قضيه قانونيه طرات خلال الساعات
الماضيه وهي ان دونالد ترامب ليس لديه
محاما يستطيع ان يكون الى جانبه داخل
المحكمه للاستماع الى لائحه الاتهامات
وهذا يعني انه سوف يحضر ولكن ربما ان لم
يحظى بالمحاما يستطيع الجلوس الى جانبه
سوف تؤخذ التسجيلات منه ولكن سوف تؤجل
عمليه احضار الاتهامات اليه الى تاريخ
متاخر طيب الى اي مدى بيار سيضرب ترامب ان
صح التعبير من بيت ابيه
بمعنى يعني تحديدا من قبل ايفان ام لا لا
يجب التعويل كثيرا على افاده القران
لادانه الرئيس ترامب
ما حدث هو ان جاك سميث المدعي في هذه
القضيه
استطاع ان يذهب الى القاضي خلال عمليات
التحقيق ويقول له ان ترامب حاول ان يتامر
مع المحامي لاخفاء ادله عن المحققين
وبالتالي رفع الغطاء القانوني والحمايه
القانونيه عن علاقه الزبون بالمحامي ووصل
الى ما وصل اليه لو عدنا الى لائحه
الاتهامات الموجوده هناك بالفعل الكلام
يستند اليه المحققون على هذه القضيه
لتوجيه تهمه
بانه حاول ان يعرقل عمل رجال القانون
والعداله ولكن هذه قضيه واحده بالمقارنه
الى قضايا اخرى تتعلق بالوثائق السريه لان
قضيه ترامب منقسمه الى قضيتين الاحتفاظ
ونقل واخفاء الوثائق والجزء الاخر المتعلق
بعمل العداله طيب الا تلاحظ انه كلما
اقترب موعد الاستحقاق الرئاسي زاد الطوق
والخناق على الرئيس ترامب ام لا لا يمكن
قول ذلك باختصار
اولا هو لم يخسر شيئا من شعبيته اخر
الاستطلاعات تشير الى ان الناخبين
الجمهوريين يعتبرون ان ترامب مستهدف من
قبل الديمقراطيين وان الديمقراطيين
يستعملون القضاء ووزاره العدل الامريكيه
ضد مرشح جدي للرئاسه الامريكيه وبالتالي
حتى لو تابع
ووزاره العدل وغيرهم رفع هذه القضايا فان
شعبيه ترب حتى الان لم تتاثر لدى
الجمهوريه طيب من واشنطن مراسل العربيه
فرغانم شكرا جزيلا لك بير على كل هذه
المتابعه
توفي رئيس الوزراء الايطاليه الاسبق سيلفي
عن عمر ناهز 86 عاما وذلك بعد صراعا مع
مرض السرطان الدم وقد دخل بيرلسقوني الى
المستشفى في ميلان وهو بحاله حرجه قبل
يومين
شاغله منصب رئيس وزراء ايطاليا في ثلاث
فترات كان اخرها عام 2011
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من جانبها رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا
ميلون برئيس الوزراء السابق سيلفي ووصفته
بانه احد الرجال الاكثر تاثيرا في تاريخ
ايطاليا
مقاتلا قبل كل شيء كان رجلا لا يخشى
الدفاع عن معتقداته مطلقا وكانت تلك
الشجاعه والتصميم هما بالضبط ما جعله احد
اكثر الرجال نفوذا في تاريخ ايطاليا وما
سمح له بصنع نقاط تحول في عالم السياسه
والاعلام وعالم الاعمال
الى روما ينضم الي لمزيد من المتابعه
مراسل العربيه رفعت النجار رفعت اهلا
وسهلا بك كيف استقبل الايطاليون نبا وفاه
بيرلس كوني مع انه الوفاه يعني كانت
متوقعه الى حد كبير وهل توضح الطبيعه
مراسم الجنازه التي ستقام له في الايام
المقبله نعم اهلا وسهلا
كان فعلا كما قلت كان كانت الوفاه متوقعه
لانه كان عن كان يعاني من مرض عضال
لا شفاء فيه
بالنسبه اولا للجنازه ستكون يوم الاربعاء
[موسيقى]
لان كل الاصدقاء من الرؤساء وغير الرؤساء
والرياضيين والسياسيين ورجال الاعلام كلهم
ارسلوا تعازيهم الى
الحكومه الايطاليه
بمجرد وفاء الاعلان وفاته فهناك الكثير
جدا
سيحضر الى ايطاليا للمشاركه في الجنازه
كان بيرلس كوني رجلا استثنائيا بالفعل
اعلاميا استثنائيا رياضيا استثنائيا
سياسيا استثنائيا
وهو الذي انشا الجمهوريه الثانيه في
ايطاليا بعد الجمهوريه الاولى التي سقطت
بعد جوليي اندريوتي السياسي المخدره من
السابق وبعد اكتشاف فساد كثير جدا هو بدا
الجمهوريه
الثانيه ووضع بصماته على كل النواحي فيها
واستطيع ان اقول لك بعض الامثله اللي انا
رفعت لا للاسف للاسف انا لضيق الوقت سنكون
معك في نشرات لاحقا للحديث عن كيف سيتذكر
الايطاليون ولكن حتى ذلك الوقت شكرا جزيلا
لك رفعت على هذه المشاركه
تواصلوا توافد الحجاج اليمنيين على منفذ
الوديع الحدودي مع السعوديه حيث استقبل
المنفذ حتى الان حوالي 4000 حاجه يمني
قدموا عبر هذا المنفذ ومن المتوقع عبوره
تسعه عشره الف حاج يمني عبر منفذ الوديعه
وقد تم تجهيزه ليضل مفتوحا حتى نهايه شهر
للقعده
[موسيقى]
امه محمد اجمعين الحمد لله هذه اول مره
نحج وانا الان اخذنا
الاحرام رمز الاحرام ومتجهين الى بيت الله
الحرام
الحج شوق لبيت الله الحرام احب البقاع الى
الله هذا المره الرابعه الفريضه الحج وكل
مره والله ازداد الشوق اكثر واكثر نسال
الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يوفقنا وجميع حجاج
بيت الله الحرام لاداء هذه الشعير العظيمه
بالوقوف بعرفات الطاهره ان شاء الله
كشف الطيران الرياض عن تصميم الهويه
البصريه والفئه الاولى من التصميم الخارجي
لاصول طائراته على ان يتم اعلان التصميم
الثاني في المستقبل القريب حيث تم اطلاقه
حفل التدشين الهويه البصريه والكشف عن
التصميم الخارجي للطائره في مطار الملك
خالد الدولي في الرياض ليمثل احتفال
العاصمه السعوديه بالناقل الوطني الجديد
قالت الحكومه السويسريه في بيان الله ان
الاداره الفيدراليه السويسريه تعرضت لهجوم
الكتروني تسبب في عرقله الوصول الى
المواقع الرسميه وبعض الشركات التابعه لها
وبحسب البيان تبنت مجموعه نونيم او بدون
اسم الهجوم الالكتروني وقالت انها مسؤوله
ايضا عن هجوم مماثل استهدف الاسبوع الماضي
موقع البرلمان
السويسري
كشف مسؤولون امريكيون عن نفوق اطنان من
الاسماك على طول ساحل خليج التكساس
وتناقلت وسائل الاعلام مشاهد للاسماك
النافقه التي غطت حافه احد شواطئ ولايه
تكساس الامريكيه
الامر الذي وصفه مسئول حياه البريه بانه
حدث نتيجه لانخفاض في الاكسجين
نشاط الخامسه من العربيه انتهتم التحيات
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات